[Applause]
giuliani is getting sued by
dominion yes which was the uh voting
vote counting machine yeah or whatever
like that and basically just for
defamation
yeah and i think the lawsuit was like
1.3 billion yeah something crazy
but i love it it's like loki
if dominion is not [ __ ] up
like if dominion is an authentic voting
machine that is not you know
brought with fraud then you should be
absolutely pissed
that's your business yeah you know what
i mean it's like you have a restaurant
and somebody's saying that you sell rats
yeah but they're saying it on the
biggest scale the highest stage
now people have no confidence in your
business and you're going to lose tons
of money i mean that should impact
my view of dominion 100 yes if someone
was like yo dominion's going to handle
the ticket sales for the next tour
whoa that's a good ass point i don't
know i mean there's got to be someone
else to handle the ticket sales or
something right you know what i mean
like there's another option you're
probably going to go for it they might
deserve that money
i think they deserve the money
especially if it's if proven that there
was no fraud
if you can prove beyond a shadow of
doubt that they're when i say no fraud
yes people are
make fraudulent votes just like anything
like a negligible amount of fraud yes
but with the machine itself was not
being manipulated
to help the democrats i mean you got to
get that money i just love the fact you
can't just say whatever you want
yeah i can get your ass suit if you're
lying on somebody sue that ass they
should sue
for all the money i also explained to me
how it's not a little [ __ ]
to not sue trump he's out of office now
well they're not suing trump i mean i
haven't seen that
oh that's [ __ ] trump lawyer rudy
giuliani the lawyer that
trump won't pay interesting though maybe
trump never said anything specific about
dominion trump is good
he's a mafioso bro this guy knows how to
rule this [ __ ] idiot giuliani
has been a prosecutor so long he don't
realize
because he got the mafia out son he
don't know exactly or maybe they're
going for trump
and this is like the person that it
funnels to ah
so you get rudy to snitch or like
they're trying to get to like they're
trying to get trump because trump is
like
it's his campaign you work your way up
to trump or something like but like
either that or like they can't get trump
because it's all through
like this legal [ __ ] you know i mean
like let's say he said something it
might not be
like if he puts out a tweet it's
different than rudy giuliani going to
court
and suing yeah yeah but the tweet is
still slander
i can get you on slaying right i don't
think you are verbally saying this one
stolen election
stealing votes blah blah blah you're
attacking the credibility of my company
that's slanders right it's liable if
it's in tweets yeah you're done
yeah but i just don't think it can be
that big of a suit i think it's like
i think that they're going for like the
big one which is giuliani being in court
like dragging them through the mud yeah
i think they just want to be a pain in
the ass
i just think they want to give these
people their uh weapons
their comeuppance yeah sue both that's
my thing
that they're not also suing him but
maybe he never said anything
specifically about it
maybe he never tweeted anything
specifically about it that's what i
think
i think he just said oh the election is
being stolen from me but he might not
have named
names yeah or or speaking code like
that dominion some funny business going
on like no actual accusation i think
it's enough to even just
lawsuit i mean yeah they might as you
lose it and then that makes you look
like i can see them leveraging a lawsuit
just to like intimidate people
yeah like if you're like ted cruz or
some other like
everybody person you're not gonna you
know keep talking that crazy talk or
maybe instead of the 1.3 billion you get
him to admit publicly that he was full
of [ __ ]
yeah yeah just admit publicly that there
is no evidence whatsoever that these
dominion machines
were designed so that they could be
manipulated because that's what they
were alleging
yeah it's not that they were manipulated
but that was part of the design
and they were saying that they have ties
to the clinton organization
oh that's right that they were from a
venezuelan company or whatever but i
think that they had ties to like the
clinton foundation or some of like the
donors were also part owners of these
companies yeah
they were they were just alleging some
crazy [ __ ] so if you're gonna talk all
that [ __ ] about me and you know that
there's no proof to support it
i'm gonna need you to keep that same
energy when you're apologizing just as
loud
right in front of the four seasons home
improvement you're gonna go right back
up there you're gonna say all that [ __ ]
was fake
yeah i don't yeah listen i'm not mad at
that same man if it's fake
if they're able to prove that and if
they prove that dominion voting machines
were [ __ ] up
yeah good then great we don't want
fraudulent voting machines in our
country
this is a win-win for everybody there's
no way you could be upset at this
because if you truly believe that they
were fraudulent you want a high-profile
court case to go see
and if you believe that they weren't you
want a high-profile court case to go see
yeah
how could anybody be upset at this yeah
no matter what we win the people
yeah i mean giuliani might be a little
bit upset but
yeah i'm saying the people right yeah
not these [ __ ] all right what
else we got so trump is making a new
or threats to make a new it's already
started
uh why are people acting like that this
doesn't exist it's not an official
like not an official thing oh he wants
an official party and they're gonna vote
patriot like the green party he wants
the patriot party great name
right now this article says the maga
party or the party i think i heard
patriot party was probably what they'll
go to because that's
better that patriot party is better mega
has such a negative connotation it's
negative contention and it's also like
make america great again like what
happens when you achieve your goal
yeah keep america great but it's never a
goal that's achieved
of course i know what i'm saying is like
that's it it's almost like always use it
yeah but like your name will imply that
you can't do what you want
like if you got everything that you
wanted it would be great again then your
party stops yeah it's a good slogan for
the first time running for president
that's why he went to keep america great
for his re-election so you can't call
the keep america great party because
then we lost how do we run
right so you have to change it up but
yeah i think that that's just the
natural course of things like
especially in america right you have the
extreme left you got the uh with a squad
or whatever like that then you have i
think you'd call them or the
bernie the squad like those are the more
extreme left and then you have
the kind of institutional left you have
like the pelosi the schumers
yeah and then you have the institutional
right that's like the bushes
marco rubio's ted cruz is flirting with
that extreme right
but you know he's such a [ __ ] loser
he's a comeback i hate this [ __ ]
yeah
but and then you have the extreme right
which is you know trump and now it seems
like cruz is kind of like falling into
that area cruz goes wherever he can get
he has no beliefs he's a spineless
[ __ ] spineless he's not even american
was he born in canada yeah
he gone yeah go back
yeah where's the [ __ ] canuck
hey [ __ ] loser
you